new leaks and rumors about the 9th
generation budget ipad have started to
emerge online
and based on what i'm seeing from these
leaks i personally believe
that a lot of people are totally wrong
so what i'm going to do in this video
is explain the specs and features that
are most likely to come
on the new ipad based on apple's past
release
trends and just simple common sense
so before we get into that let me show
you all of those leaks
back in november ipad 9 rumors started
by triple zero leaker on twitter
claiming that ming chakuo expects a new
ipad 9
to be released in the second half of
2021
with an updated design then in december
a report
from chinese website cn beta claimed
that the ipad 9 would come
with an a13 chip 4 gigs of ram
64 gigs of base storage and a 10.5 inch
display
with a starting price of 299 dollars
which is even lower than the current
model and then finally
just a couple of days ago mac otakara
claimed that the new ipad will feature a
thinner
lighter design with a touch id home
button and a lightning port
but they expect the display size to
remain the same
10.2 inches so that's basically all that
we've got in terms of leaks
and as you can tell they're all
conflicting with each other
in one way or another and i personally
think a lot of those details
are totally wrong let me explain the
first way i want to attack those rumors
is by looking at what apple's done
with the budget ipad in the past apple's
fifth generation ipad came
with the old 9.7 inch display with a
home button
and a non-laminated display then with
the ipad 6
apple upgraded it with an a10 chip and
apple pencil support but they kept the
same
9.7 inch display the year after that the
ipad 7 kept
the same exact a10 chip but they added
the smart connector
and changed the design to feature a new
10.2 inch display and then just a few
months ago
apple released the ipad 8 and the only
difference
was the upgraded a12 chip that's
literally
the only change so from all of that
there are a couple of different things
that we can learn
number one is that apple has been
updating their budget ipad
every single year and two apple has been
extremely conservative
with their year over year upgrades and
if you look at the trends from the past
few ipads
apple seems to have it on a tick-tock
upgrade cycle
one year they upgrade the design without
changing the chip
and the next year they upgrade the chip
without changing the design
so if we assume that apple will continue
with this trend
then we can expect that the ipad 9
coming sometime this year
will most likely stick to the same a12
bionic chip not the a13 like many of
those leakers
are claiming and keep in mind that for a
budget ipad
the a12 is definitely powerful enough so
that means that if apple is not
upgrading the chip this year then the
likely upgrade the design so let's talk
about what apple can do with that
if we look at the history of the budget
ipad it was always taking
hand-me-downs from the more expensive
ipads
in terms of technology for example it
was the last
larger sized ipad to get the smart
connector and it still has
a cheap non-laminated display without p3
wide color gamut support
it still doesn't have an anti-reflective
coating
it still has the most outdated a12 chip
and it still features
a horrible 1.2 megapixel selfie camera
and of course all of that makes sense
because this is the budget ipad that
we're talking about
priced at only 329 so based on that
logic
we can expect the budget ipad line to be
the very last
to get updated with a new edge to edge
display design
as we've already seen apple do with the
ipad pro
and the ipad air 4. so based on what
apple has done in the past
the new ipad 9 will likely stick to the
older
home button design for at least one more
year and since they just updated the
chip
last year apple will probably update the
design
this year so the big question is this
if they're not gonna give it the full
flat back redesign
what exactly is gonna change in my
personal opinion
it makes the most sense to give the ipad
9 the same exact body
and 10.5 inch display as the ipad air
3. this is the absolute easiest route
for apple to take
since they already have all of the
tooling and the internals
ready to go and as we already know the
ipad air 4 uses a totally new design
based on the ipad pro so apple can
simply take
the ipad air 3 and change nothing at all
except for giving it a weaker a12 chip
and
boom there you go that's the new ipad 9.
it's going to be just good enough to
make it worth it since the biggest
downside of the ipad 8
is the non-laminated display that really
sucks
compared to the rest of the lineup as
well as the horrible
selfie camera giving the ipad 9 the same
design as the air 3
will fix both of those issues and it's
going to be easy on
apple since it'll support the same
keyboard cases
that the ipad air 3 supported this is
the path of least resistance
so i personally expect apple to go this
route
this would also mean that the touch id
home button is staying
the lightning port is staying and the
first gen apple pencil support
is staying now in terms of the specs and
the price i personally expect the ipad 9
to get the same
three gigs of ram with that a12 chip
i expect the storage to stick with the
same 32 gigabytes at the base
price which you might disagree with but
if you think about it
the new ipad air 4 comes with 64 gigs
and it costs
600 apple giving the budget ipad
64 gigs of storage would be really
shocking
since i personally expect the price to
stick to the same 329
which goes against those other rumors
that we talked about
which claimed apple would lower the
price to 299
i completely disagree with them because
i personally believe
that apple is attempting to raise the
price of their entire ipad lineup
they did it with the redesigned ipad pro
in 2018.
they did it with the redesigned ipad air
4 just a few months ago
so to me it makes the most sense to keep
the price of the budget ipad
at the same 329 until
they finally give the ipad the modern
flat back
inside full redesign with support for
the 2nd gen apple pencil
which will be enough for apple to
justify raising the price
to 399 now out of all of the
speculations that i just made
there is only one thing that i'm unsure
about
whether apple intends to give the ipad
the full
redesign next year or two years from now
if you think about it two years sounds
like a very long time for it to stick
with the old design
but then apple would be staying true to
their tick-tock
upgrade cycle of new design and then new
chip this would mean that next year's
ipad would get the a14
chip with no other major changes and
then two years from now
it would finally get a full redesign but
stick to the same a14 chip but then
on the other hand what if apple is
planning to give it the full redesign
next year so they can raise the base
price
this would mean that they would be
giving the ipad a new design
two years in a row which would be
breaking the cycle
since they would also need to update the
chip at some point
as well so here's my theory for option
number two
what if apple quite literally takes the
ipad air 3
with its a13 bionic chip and 4 gigabytes
of ram
and simply rebrands it as the ipad 9.
this would by far be the easiest route
to take
and it would allow them to fully
redesign the ipad
next year while keeping the same a13
chip
on that new model those are the two
options and as
of right now i'm not really sure which
one apple is going to go with
but with all of that said the only
remaining question
is when the ipad 9 is going to be
released so let's quickly answer that
for the past few years
apple's budget ipads have been released
in either september
or march with the most recent ipad 8
being released in september and recent
leaks are pointing to both the ipad pro
and the ipad mini 6 to get released this
upcoming march so in my personal opinion
it doesn't make sense to release three
out of the four ipad models
all at the same time in march so we can
safely assume
that the ipad 9 is probably coming this
september
or at the very least sometime this fall
so to finish off this video
here's a full spec list of what i expect
for the 2021 ipad 9 so you can
screenshot this
if you'd like to share this with others
now if you totally disagree with me
go ahead and comment your thoughts down
below but if you enjoyed it
click that circle above to subscribe and
definitely watch those ipad league
videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
you